amazing lineup of CEOs Founders and
experts this is marketing for the now
[Music]
thank you so much
[Music]
Gary
Andrea big day for you
yes do you have anything to show over
there on that table yeah as you know
like uh obviously a lot going on in uh V
friends land but uh but that's for
another time in another day
yes yeah today we're gonna crack the
code on Speed and Agility and a favorite
topic of yours I know
um we've got some great a great lineup
today and we're gonna kick things off
with Andy rebbin he is the CMO of El
Pollo Loco and it's interesting as I was
kind of searching up a little bit about
his background he has a video that's
called Beanie Babies McNuggets and oh my
how a childhood hustle evolved into a
winning mentality in digital uh in
addition to El Pollo Loco he's obviously
worked at McDonald's and Ford and he may
have something to show you part way
through your conversation I don't know
but I can't wait to hear you guys
awesome how are you my friend I'm good
good to see you today great to see you
Andy look I think this show goes quick
you're about to find out so let's just
go right into it given that incredible
intro the entrepreneurial background you
know I think gives you gives me an
advantage of understanding Speed and
Agility because there really is no other
option when you come up that track
whereas if you go through a classic
track of school and corporate
one can argue that that is not
necessarily the kpis what is cracking
the code for all the entrepreneurs or
all the executives because we have a
good mix of both watching when you hear
this question posed what stands out Andy
I think the biggest thing is just taking
the opportunity and taking the chances
when presented I really like to lean in
pretty heavily and I would say that you
know six moves in 11 years in Corporate
America Kansas City Detroit Boston
Chicago Atlanta La uh you got to be
really willing to chase the opportunity
and where that opportunity is and you
know really just keep a pulse on Trends
uh you know Andrea did a nice job
talking about Beanie Babies I sold my
first beanie baby at 12 years old for
250 dollars to a card in the mall and uh
you know that's just something that I'm
super passionate about got into eBay
really early and uh
uh I got into eBay probably 2 000-ish
maybe 1999 but I was young at the time
that was like 12 13 years old for me so
I was selling all my neighbors stuff and
uh it was a really good way to make
extra money
what um give an example of like striking
when the opening's there that you think
is more mapping towards a corporate
company you know think about the
restaurant group that you're in right
now like what does that give me a four
instance like if this happens we would
think this way right
um so leaning in heavily I would say to
tick tock we had a for instance where we
saw that birya was a food product that
was trending heavily in the LA area and
we moved very quickly normally it takes
you know call it 9 12 24 months to kind
of develop that product life cycle and
we said we have to do it in three we
have to do it and you know quicker than
six and we hit while the iron was hot it
was our best selling product ever in the
company's 41 year history and we broke
uh sales records for three weeks
straight uh for our overall annual unit
volumes and so leaned in heavily there
move quickly our franchisees were
supportive we got the operations group
very involved and made it box
financially so it was a really
successful uh lto product for us and and
now what like is everyone kind of like
okay wait a minute like this needs to be
the norm like this that do people
realize that this wasn't a one-off and
it's replicatable or do they think it
was a a one-off no I think it's
replicatable I think you really have to
just make sure you engage your supply
chain folks early because I think in the
global supply chain crisis that we're in
right now clearly you have to be able to
understand the Dynamics of marketplace
fluctuations and really just continuing
to keep a pulse on the consumer I mean
that's that's the biggest piece Foods
Trends food Trends change every single
day and uh you know we just want to be
at the center of it and it's super
important to us and we feel like we can
lean in quickly again
but um what's the biggest thing that
stops big orgs from getting there in
your opinion I think bureaucracy I think
too many cooks in the kitchen I think
having a single decision maker uh really
helps speed along the process and I
think alignment is key too
um making sure that all cross-functional
subjects are brought in early and often
can really lead to acceleration of
making things happen and I think
sometimes in some of the larger
organizations I was a part of I learned
so much and how to be a student of the
business but I think lots of times there
were so many layers that it prevented uh
Innovation and Speed and Agility from
happening do you think that's the human
trait of insecurity
I mean you know I think about this a lot
like to your point like when I see
things going slow in my company where we
have a lot of safety because I'm really
a
high energy active founder CEO and so
you know that that's what companies take
on that personality like it's always
fear that is holding people up like this
person even though they heard me that
they're safe don't believe me because
they've worked at other places where
they're not safe and then because of
that consciously and sometimes
subconsciously maybe even half the time
subconsciously they start playing
politics which just slows everything
down yeah I think part of it is fear of
missing out I think part of it is people
want to be a part of things that they
think will succeed for the organization
but I think in kind of yeah you mean
success has a million fathers failure
has none
exactly but I also think in parallel
though some people are scared of making
mistakes I mean lots of times you need
to swing the bat
um and just be okay with making mistakes
James Joyce one of my favorite quotes
mistakes or the portrayal of Discovery
to me it's like you need to learn you
got to fail fast iterate and get better
and I think sometimes that's not you
know an option in big orgs
before we get you out of here in a
couple minutes what what else have we
not touched on thematically or a tidbit
or a kid coming up that wants to get
into like what what we would not talked
about from Speed and Agility that you
think makes sense yeah I mean I think
one of the biggest pieces is learn from
people who do it well and learn from
people who fail I think lots of case
studies are great I think connecting on
LinkedIn is huge uh I'm a big believer
in mentorship and um let's give let's
give some roses to some people before we
get out of here who was a mentor to that
you think really brought you value
through your career uh there's a couple
uh Musa Tariq who's the current CMO of
GoFundMe uh incredible human being and
great friend of mine
um I would say Greg Watson who is one of
my former managers at McDonald's uh
Julia vanderplug uh who was former Chief
digital officer at Hyatt uh and then
Neil golden
um who is on the board of RBI uh former
CMO of McDonald's just incredible people
who have challenged me made me better
and just given me so much time that I'm
grateful for
I love that uh got another minute or two
why don't I just throw a little
curveball on you I like The Tick Tock
call out what has most surprised you
about the rise of tick tock in the last
three years as a pretty contemporary
marketer yourself and coming up the
ranks and I know moose is super well and
some of the other names you mentioned
um we kind of come from the same schools
like
if I ask you the biggest thing that
surprised you how would you answer that
I would say how quickly uh CEO and the
board was ready to adapt
um I think they're really scared
initially to lean in and understand that
a big part of our media spend was going
to go to influencers and shifting over
to the authentic platform that's Tick
Tock and um very quickly we were able to
show them results increase in engagement
and just really uh just the brand
expanding casting a wider net was huge I
think there was a little bit of you know
timidness of can we really abandon TV
that quickly and I was really excited
about how we leaned in and how the board
and the CEO were very supportive of it I
love it Andy thank you so much brother
continued success out there thanks Gary
take care
thanks Andy next up we welcome Jade
Livingston the CMO of Shake Shack Jay is
responsible for marketing the digital
experience and all things product a
couple of cool facts about Jay he's an
angel investor in over 30 startups he's
produced several feature films and he's
a foundering a founding member of unite
America welcome Jane
Gary thank you that's good I'm so glad
you're here
um
how long how long have you been CMO of
Shake Shack be four years in January
yeah I thought it was that's great so
yeah we were in a dinner I was CMO of
BarkBox uh yeah I remember in Bank of
America before that yeah I remember
um
so given BarkBox which obviously I was
wrote one of the first checks into that
company
um Shake Shack young but you're catching
it you know further along than the Bark
Box and then obviously Bank of America I
think you're actually based on the last
conversation and sitting in an
incredible spot I would call it like
big medium small in a lot of ways if you
know
themes that are similar differences
you know or just you're maybe even to
start here and opening rant on what is
what is the Maneuvers needed to crack
the code on Speed and Agility and maybe
in all three of those buckets given that
you really have touched things that very
interesting times
well one thing I think companies people
that work at these big companies do
themselves a disservice when they
discount small companies and vice versa
right the startups saying oh they're too
slow at the big companies we have
nothing to learn from them we're not
going to hire from them we want people
from other growth companies to come in
here and help us and then the big
companies have the same sort of uh blind
spot I think there's actually a ton you
can learn from both like I kind of can
see the future because I've I've been in
the future before I know what growth
there's nothing that I run into any day
that I say man I don't know how to
handle this because frankly we had to
handle it all at a big company if you're
there long enough right so you can kind
of see the future what you can't let
that do is give you blinders so that you
start you stop innovating and being
curious and thinking that everything is
gonna just not pivot and change which is
such a skill you have to have at a
Growth Company being able to react
quickly to those uh that's the thing
that took me a minute I think when I got
to bark even Shake Shack was there are
two things I didn't understand I didn't
understand social media uh Performance
Marketing growth marketing at Bank of
America because we didn't really have to
do it so that was something I had to
learn
um and then secondly I didn't realize
how quickly you had to make decisions
right it's just the speed of decision
making that uh you have to bring more
Instinct one of my mantras have said is
like we need to be a more data a
fact-based decision-making organization
but we're still sort of instinct LED and
that takes a minute to get used to if
you come from a big company but it's a
great combination and we try to embrace
it
I love that I love that what um what is
Shake Shack thinking about right now
from a speed agility or really speeding
agility is just a
framework that gets you to relevance
right and so or at least one of the
things that gets you to and so
what's kind of hot you know I think
there's a lot of love for this brand and
so I well I got you give me a little of
what's hot
well one is I'm lucky to be part of the
passion brand that like when we open in
Manila we have people scalping burgers
out front uh that we have to put a limit
on the number of burgers that are open
because they'll scalp them for 20 bucks
out front so that's something you can't
really design for you know when Danny
Meyer founded the restaurant we never
guessed that there would be that kind of
avidity it's not something you can
advertise your way into it has to be all
about the experience and everything else
I think uh we're also opening a Shake
Shack somewhere in the world every few
days so that kind of pace and growth uh
you know is is something we're super
focused on I'd say what's hot is I
always say as a marketer our job is to
go where the eyeballs are and I want to
get ahead of where those eyeballs are
going right like that doesn't mean these
Legacy platforms are going away I'm sure
when uh radio came out newspapers
thought well we're done and when
television out radio
you're never dead you just become a
overpriced
right like like the TV commercial I've
seen TV commercials my argument is that
not that they're not getting seen
they're not getting seen against the
costs associated with producing a
commercial and the media associated with
it what you know I'm sure I I mean I've
seen banner ads on espn.com they're
expensive against the cost of the
impression and the creative to actually
get me to do something that's where the
argument becomes passionate for me
correct and that's why the job of a of a
marketer is to constantly be hacking our
way into where those eyeballs are going
doesn't mean you drop everything else
that you may have experience in this
work into some degree but yeah we want
to be you know the thing is if you look
back to Industry last five years just
social platforms so we have big
Instagram engagement we have big
engagement on a lot of our social media
platforms we're always thinking about
okay we gotta have to invest in three or
four of these we don't know which one's
gonna win but when one of them be real
or Tick Tock or you name it starts to
LEAP we already want to have a little
bit of experience a little something
that's right yeah and my job is to
convince
um I see a our CEO like hey we got to
spend a little money here three of these
are gonna fail but if we're an early
mover okay is it is it a game of sorry
to interrupt is it a game of convincing
for more budget or is it a game of you
sitting at the top of marketing saying
you know what I haven't been feeling
great about the ROI lately on this
direct mail or this Banner ad or this
outdoor or this Facebook let me just
carve out a couple hundred k out of this
and plop it here
or is it some is it sometimes one or the
other like how does it play out just to
give a little under the hood for the
kids at home I think it's both I think
it's both because you got to have the
organization sort of backing you like if
you're making a bunch of bets that
nobody really understands or knows that
CFO and C CEO and then those things are
failing and you haven't established how
you want it to work you could be in a
little trouble right I position it like
very similar to Angel Investing if I've
got a portfolio of 30 companies like I
know that 25 of those are not going to
fly right I'm hoping three of them do
pretty well and I'm hoping the other two
make the entire thing and it's a similar
way in social media and some of these
platforms right now like I'm gonna have
to take some Investments knowing that
several of them aren't going to work but
man if you were early if you're super
early on Tick Tock and you were out
there like even with a small getting a
small understanding think about this
Spades that's paying off in now
um whereas there were several
Investments we've made that you know you
might not feel that way as much about
yeah what um what about
um
what about the best
Roi you felt from a fast move and the
one that you most had confidence for
that didn't pan out little win and loss
moment here for everybody to hear about
the wins and the losses and you're
thinking behind them could be a Bank of
America it could be a bark could be a
Shake Shack could be a something you saw
because you were an investor and want to
come but but you I think it's it's more
personal when it's you something you
really backed that didn't pan out
something that you really backed that
did pan out around Speed and Agility in
first mover or early mover in a thing
one that didn't you know you want to be
an experiential brand I'll give you the
most recent one I've got a whole history
of them but when covid broke out we came
up with this concept called Shack camp
and the idea was like all these people
kids families are sitting at home
they've got nothing to do let's develop
a box that's like if you're if you love
The Shake Shack experience let's put all
these thing in the Box let's do videos
around every day for Camp so five days
of Camp you get to engage we got a
recipe in there we'll give you some
cooking tools you can make food one day
with your family you can do all these
different things well it turns out we
weren't great at putting that box
together it was quite expensive it had
40 items in it we had a lot of loyal
customers who bought it
um and we did these great videos around
it but the Box we ended up taking a
little bit of a bath on how much we
spent on it versus how much we made
um and that was a little bit humbling
because uh it was just something outside
of our comfort zone I think it was worth
I think think it was worth the
experiment but yeah it didn't work
so that that was one that you've always
got to be careful when you really get
outside of doing something that is
totally not something you that was a
little a little hubris on on our part I
part to think that we could pull that
off in that way uh so so that was one I
was not maybe my best moment of all time
um I think places that we've leaned into
uh
you know we we're we're we've pivoted to
we used to do a bunch of chef collabs
with like 10 11 12 chefs a year where at
Madison Square Park we'd have some
um local Chef that we would put a bunch
of money into develop a burger with we'd
sell a bunch of tickets and it made a
great impact locally but it had no scale
so one of the things we've done is we're
only going to do three of those a year
right and so much of like marketing and
success is focusing on what works doing
less but then when it works piling on
the money right it's this whole idea of
like when you play Blackjack it's one
hand out of 40 that you make your money
on and that's where you have to have the
Readiness to like go all in and put the
money behind it so we're gonna do like
three this year but they're going to be
major and they're going to hit big
audiences and we're going to put
resources behind them and we know that
that's going to work in a way that
because we did one last year and that
way that that's going to really like
take off nationally and now instead of
like trying to defend each one of these
small ones we got one big one that has
real scale across I love it Brother Jay
real pleasure good to see you again
cheering for you brother yeah thanks man
appreciate it thanks Jay
Gary I'm really fired up about this next
one it's Kat stickler
she is one of tick tock's beloved Stars
eight million oh here she is
on this whole time backstage I don't
even know what to do
all right I'm gonna let you guys just
take it from here she's gonna tell you
everything she's doing
enjoy
take it away
God it's such a pleasure how are you I
am so good I'm so good I've been playing
I was freaking out freaking out like
literally
why I
because that's how I express emotion
it's just good for you
why don't you tell everybody a little
bit about yourself
I'm Kat stickler I'm an Entertainer I
love making people laugh it's my passion
and um
I was able to do that and reach a lot of
people through Tick Tock by doing that
what made you jump on tick tock
I was late in the game I was two years
into it and I was like okay let's try
this covet happened that's why I jumped
in I was
a stay-at-home mom and then
I got bored when the baby was napping so
I just thought she was my only friend
and then I kind of took off from there
what first happened
like which first uh you made how many
tick tocks did you make before you had a
viral one let's start with that
how many tick tocks did I make before I
had a buyer one one two three
four five probably ten
okay now let's tell the story of the
first viral one so you post your 11th
your 12th your ninth your 16th what
happens
it was more relatability at that point
so I knew that what would hit was if
comments were engaged with what's
relatable and someone could pitch it on
every single thing I've touched
um man woman child so that was when I
realized okay if I can get more people
to relate to it and that means the
comedy can reach bigger audience so and
did you meaning
did you like feel like you were gonna
hit like when you posted it you're like
this is the one or was it the right so
that's where it gets interesting for me
like
so when you when it hits are you like oh
I've got something here or like this
platform's different because what Tick
Tock brought to the table was virality
for people that didn't have millions of
followers and I feel like a lot of
people calibrated that as like oh this
is a different opportunity is that what
you felt
yeah I felt like it was just an insane
gift to be able to reach that many
people I was like holy [ __ ] this is like
I feel like someone gave me this box and
like I didn't want it to break and I'm
like I need to be perfect thanks yeah I
didn't want to throw it away and then um
no I think it was both I think it's both
the platform and I think
because if I post the same video that
went viral on Tick Tock and I posted on
Instagram
one or two have gone viral on Instagram
but it's it's not the same Instagram
like likes a different kind of video
yeah I mean I think people's psychology
when they're on the platform is
different and the audience is different
and the algorithms are different like
it's just different
you're so smart yeah yeah totally
what um what uh what do you think you're
smart about so I appreciate that
compliment let me give it back to you
like right now if I'm like hey shoot
your shot of what you're feeling strong
about like what do you think you have
grasped that a lot of other people
haven't figured out in this world right
now
I wouldn't necessarily say that a lot of
other people have figured it out but I
think I have a pretty good understanding
of when to
put humor into things I got divorced and
no one jokes about getting divorced it's
like taboo
um and I kind of like my mother you know
I made her I impersonate my mom I mean
you have to be very religious like she's
like putting holy water on me so I
really tried to make light of things
that people go through
um I think I do have that
um I don't I don't like saying I have
that gift I don't know I think I can
communicate trauma in a way like after
you heal that there's like Hope on the
other end I love that
do you feel like you always knew you had
it
oh yeah I mean I want to talk about my
confidence
mine too but I want to talk about this
there's a lot of people watching right
now who believe the same thing that
haven't made the jump yet
what do you think about that like what
when I say that because I know it to be
true because because I pushed this out
so much I'm on the receiving end of so
many people reaching out to me and
saying you [ __ ] I love you so
much like you pounded me until I finally
did it and it's [ __ ] happening how'd
you know and I'm like I'm like I know
because
like the world is now in a place we used
to have the thing of like 15 minutes of
fame and now we have like everybody has
15 fans like everybody has 15 fans some
people just have 15 million fans and
they have it in them they don't realize
that they even have any fans yet but
they kind of know they have something
right but they're scared to make that
jump because they are now playing a
character of themselves in their
grown-up self right you know the energy
you bring like in the beginning and just
like people listening to you right now
like
you know I think you're going to be able
to reach people that maybe I can't
because they associate more you might
say different words like what stands out
when you hear that
um that Ira kind of overcame
embarrassment in my own life like
I got it was an unexpected pregnancy it
was just casually dating and then boom
and then I was the last person you would
expect my parents everyone had shocked
everyone around me knew and I like walk
around with this belly and like so off
you can't hide it you're like yeah I'm
pregnant
um so I think overcoming that and just
owning my decisions all of a sudden I
didn't care at all like it like went it
went like so that life event of like
you're not the person that's gonna do
this went so the other way and unlocked
actually a lot of happiness because you
were like [ __ ] it what's worse than this
judgment yeah
is powerful
and I think also
I forgot what I was going to say sorry
sorry
I am sweating just dressed why
that's how I was made I don't know God
but yourself I was gonna lean back in my
chair okay but you're but you're an
Entertainer you shouldn't be nervous
right yeah
sure you're super nervous right I'm
never nervous because I've gotten my
brain into similar to you like I don't
know if it was you know I've been
thinking a lot about something lately
both of my parents lost a parent very
young
my mom lost her mom at five
and my dad lost his dad at 15. and I've
been remembering lately of like wow I
really feared my parents dying when I
was a kid because it was in the air
it was their lives right
and I wonder if like I've been thinking
a lot about this lately of like Wyatt
do I not give a [ __ ] you know like yes I
got bad grades and like everybody said I
was gonna suck and I knew I wasn't but
lately I've been going into like am I
just so grateful that I got to 46 and my
parents are both alive and healthy and
like am I just so simple like do I just
have I figured it out which is like [ __ ]
everything nothing matters like it's all
good like and I'm trying to scale that
in conversation you know
this is the Gratitude gorilla okay all
right I'm gonna make this [ __ ]
character so beloved and so adored by
every human on earth that hopefully it
seeps gratitude into everyone's head
because once you're grateful everything
gets easy if you're actually grateful if
you don't all the [ __ ] I'm so
grateful you know [ __ ] grateful you
complain that your coffee wasn't hot you
can't do that when you're grateful right
oh that's so good I I totally agree with
that just because
it's so easy to get like just not be
yourself with this thing it's such like
an ego boost when someone comes up to
you like oh my gosh you did this for me
I'm like you get it all the time but
just keeping that being humble let's see
I love that well I love that I love that
you're bringing this up we'll wrap up
with this I don't know how by the way I
have no idea what the [ __ ] this has to
do with Speed and Agility but oh right
this is the best conversation that's
perfect because actually peace of mind
and like inner Inner Strength actually
leads to all Speed and Agility the
reason I'm fast and agile is I don't
care when I fail
right
but to your point if you don't hear the
accolades
humility you're not vulnerable to the
hate
right and I feel like everyone has this
like a little bit of
unfortunately this like depravity in
them and I think when you have these
people like saying horrible things and
if they bring up my daughter I'm like oh
[ __ ] no way but
I would literally watch your things all
the time because I don't really care
what people think about me anymore and
it's so
I don't know I can do anything I guess I
feel like that's the only piece of
advice once you don't care like you
don't care if you post and your friends
see it and what will they think and you
don't care because I failed at so many
freaking videos so many have flopped
like I'm just used to it it's okay I'm
proud of you cat thank you so much for
being on the show
oh I just love that
I gotta run a run have a great rest of
the show love you guys
love that cat
she is crazy all right let's bring up
Ryan Harwood the CEO of gallery Media
Group Ryan hey Andrew how are you that
is that was that was one interview
wasn't it
cat was amazing when she popped on and
she was just like I'm here that was
great
oh my god oh super fired up we're gonna
have Ulta Beauties Carla Davis coming up
next let's bring her on she's the
integrated marketing Communications and
media team lead with seven years of
experience there and Carl I have to say
I'm personally just really passionate
about your commitment to diversity and
inclusion and I'm sure you'll be talking
about that a little bit more with Ryan
take it away no but I mean man like
coming off of her I'm like I gotta bring
way more energy like there's lots of
love in the chat lots of love good to
see you hey Ryan hey Carla how's it
going it's good good for Thursday
totally yeah no we do get it we have to
bring the heat after a conversation like
that
for real
yeah and I love marketing for the now
because I too interview my favorite
marketers and my favorite humans in the
industry so I'm really really excited
and flattered to be with be here with
you today yeah this is a great one I'm
looking forward to it
so Andrea just mentioned you've been
with Ulta for seven years now uh you
know the beauty industry has obviously
changed a lot even in that seven years
how has the company changed over the
last seven years and how have you
personally changed as a marketer yeah no
I mean like when I first came in so
seven years in some ways that feels like
light year you know a million years ago
but it was always a phenomenal retailer
right like it has and continues to have
an amazing retail proposition I think
that it's been building and you know
want to give our team a little credit to
become a great brand right when I first
started there was so much great that we
sold people didn't really know what we
stood for though if we really were to
kind of pull it apart and said like hey
there's there's so much we can wrap
around what we already have and elevate
it and like that's that's been the work
the last seven years kind of given given
Ulta beauty something to stand for and
to make it meaningful to people
um and you know a really important way
I love that and how have you personally
changed as a marketer yeah oh my gosh so
I am you know kind of old school come
from traditional cpg kind of background
and when I tell you like so much of the
work was like okay we gotta build
foundations like Basics while also
trying to look around the corner and
like catch up like that that was a lot
right like trying to figure out how to
do both at the same time and a lot of it
like feeling comfortable in what I knew
and knowing that I'm gonna have to
figure out new stuff as we go so it
definitely brought a lot of a lot of
anxiety had to kind of get into a
comfort level of like all right where
are we now and how do we have to focus
while also like being open to doing
different things I jokingly say now you
know we're seven years old we're a first
grader I have a first grader I know what
that's like right you got to keep them
focused but also help people a whole lot
of Grace and I find that like that's
what I've had to really Embrace as a
marketer you know is how do you keep
some focus focus on ultimately what's
going to matter to that guest and give
yourself some Grace and recognizing that
like this stuff's going to have to turn
and turn and that's okay and you're
going to figure it out as you go yeah
you know what steps are you taking to be
agile in your beauty world and do you
think I'm curious when you give your
answer do you think you would have given
that same answer a few years back
pre-coveted yeah so I'll well part of
the if the last one is no I've got a
totally different way of thinking about
it but like seriously I think the the
element that we had to get really
comfortable with on the first end is
like thoughtfulness and rigor does not
have to come with like preciousness
right like definitely when I think about
as a retailer and coming again out of
consumer package Goods we do more
programming and changes and and new
things out in the market in a quarter
than we often did in a year so just
inherently retail moves you faster than
it did when I was kind of coming and
from the brand side and so you've got to
get a lot less precious you know like
we've jokingly started to talk about
like reality is got to be a little bit
like toilet paper you know it's gonna be
extra useful in the short term but you
know it's going to get disposed of so
like let's lean into knowing what our
intent is getting way more focused on
our intent and I think that that's also
something like figuring out your intent
faster getting to what's the role what's
the goal of what you're trying to do
staying maniacally focused to that but
then also being able to say hey if we
get it done is better than you know
nitpicking on getting it perfect and
really having to kind of start taking
that adage of like you know progress
over Perfection you know and then that
is the biggest difference I think like
previously we did do so much stuff
because we still were so much in a
little bit more of a traditional mindset
of like building Brands takes all of
this really really
um big thought and in a way it still
takes thoughtfulness but it cannot come
at the detriment of getting things out
learning and moving to the next thing
and the pandemic was definitely where I
think we learned that muscle a ton more
than we ever had before
we call it the end mentality instead of
the ore mentality because when it's or
you're debating over things that
probably mean nothing to the consumer
it's just this creative Authority where
if we say let's do both and get it out
quick you're going to be able to
integrate that so I love that yeah and
what do you think speed means how
important is speed to the beauty
industry specifically right now and when
you are moving with such speed
how do you avoid pitfalls when operating
so quickly man in fact in Beauty like
let's just talk about especially these
last couple of years right like it has
shown so much of a cultural relevance
and cultural Force right like if nothing
else this idea of indeed identity how we
identify why it's important how we
identify and how much like that is such
a driving force for whether or not folks
will cancel you will feel like you get
it like and and Beauty sits so at a core
of a lot of that and so one I think that
that's the close the connection to speed
is its cultural relevance like and that
is absolutely where you can make these
missteps right like you can't over woke
everybody out there but you have to be a
certain amount of it to make sure that
like as you are kind of creating these
things you don't inadvertently step in
something that like you can't then now
um you know or like react to quickly and
and I think part of that even comes with
like this authentic like authenticity of
being recognizing that like we will move
with humility but with speed we will
acknowledge if we get it wrong because
that's something else that I think when
you're in this space now like you're not
gonna get it right so like what's your
willingness to call it when you didn't
um a verse pretend like it didn't happen
because I think that elevation of
expectation is now happening and those
those um pitfalls have to come with a
willingness to do that
um and for folks to at least see like
Hey we're growing with this as we go and
we're willing to say yep that didn't
work you know
totally last question here you know last
year you conceptualized and executed
executed an amazing program as an
award-winning program called Muse it was
to honor black Americans contributions
to beauty and culture you know this year
I saw that ultimate of 50 million dollar
investment in diversity equity and
inclusion
tell me more about that
no so we can say like as Ulta beauty it
has always been kind of implicit in who
we are that like we're we're here to
break barriers of things how they have
been or expected right like we were the
first place to say we're gonna put a 20
lipstick and a five dollar lipstick in
the same place and guess what it's not
gonna like break the system you know
it's like why why is it that that does
not exist why isn't there some level of
democracy in how people can engage with
beauty but it has been a process to be
you know really transparent with
ensuring our entire organization
explicitly operates in a way that brings
that democracy through all of our things
through the way we message where we
message who we message for right like
that hasn't always been at the Forefront
of how we have worked and so Muse really
was our first effort to say you know
what as much as this might be a
component of how we have believed we
need to make it like core to how we show
up how we're gonna walk the walk of all
of this and and yeah it is still a
process we are so not all the way where
we need to be but it has us as an entire
Enterprise thinking about where we put
our money who we support you know how we
train our Associates and making sure
that like everybody's vested and that
it's showing up in a meaningful way so
it's it's really a proud moment for me
and for the organization to be doing
something like this
I love it my Infamous speed round of
questions we're going to go into this
and we're going to wrap up here so let's
get to Know Carl a little bit better
early riser or night owl ah night uh
gotta do it in the evenings
me too beauty product you cannot live
without oh gosh product
individual I don't know I gotta cheat a
little bit it's probably skin care but I
will say like Shiseido has given me all
kinds of right now you know try to keep
the skin together
over Tick Tock as a consumer uh I do IG
all day I can't figure out the the young
kids got the content like the way they
do it I'm still working on that
and last one I saw on Instagram you you
went to Serena Williams's last match one
to ten what was that experience like I
mean like 125 like I mean lifetime
experience like the energy there what it
meant for the business the Indus like
sports would have been for my my
six-year-old that I gotta take along
with me for her to see how loved this
black woman was in this sport
um and just in this world like yeah
Second To None it's such a cool
experience
so much for joining us today Carla I
really appreciate it
awesome bye thank you Carla
that was a great one we got a lot of men
and women lighting up the chat on that
one Ryan the guys are like I gotta
understand why is my wife spending all
kinds of time and money at Ulta but now
now I guess we know right all right we
got another good one Ryan we got Sarah
Larson who comes to us from Samsung home
entertainment there she is she runs the
integrated marketing team she is a trend
Spotter and she gets a little help from
her two teenage daughters it sounds like
I I have the same thing going on my
house where they tell me what's actually
cool
so excited to have you join us today
Sarah thanks hey Sarah hey Ryan how's it
going today it's good I'm glad to be
here with you although I feel like I
should be fangirling a little bit more
after the earlier interviews I'm
definitely not ready to scream at the
top of my life
well for everybody in the audience I've
known Sarah a very very long time she
was one of the first people that I had
the privilege of meeting in the industry
back when I started pure wow almost 12
years ago so we've kept in touch and I'm
thrilled to have you on the show today
and talk a little bit about Samsung
marketing with home electronics so thank
you for joining us my pleasure and 12
years ago that must have mean it was we
were like teenagers when we met exactly
exactly
so let's talk a little bit about Speed
and Agility you know Speed and Agility
is though it feels like the lifeblood of
a sector like Tech
how do you keep yourself and your team
Nimble with so many changes going on to
technology
yeah totally you know my boss James
Fishler always says what got us here
won't get us there and I think that
mindset is something that permeates
through Samsung and certainly on the
home entertainment team we are just big
proponents of veracious reading
consuming every type of media and
inspiration that we can and for me
personally I like to look at more
non-traditional too so I definitely will
consume everything that we're expected
to know and understand as marketers but
then it's you know fault talking to my
teenagers for Real about what's hot with
them and what's going on it's connecting
with people through social media and all
of my networking I feel like you never
know where a conversation is going to
lead and I'm so fortunate that at
Samsung we really push boundaries and
defy barriers in that sort of way that
we're constantly pushing ourselves to
just basically be better
that's awesome and you know Samsung as a
company and all your products it just
seems to be at the Nexus of tech and
style utility and Mobility how do you
keep yourself personally abreast of
changes in all of those different
sectors and and also like what is your
daily consumption like to keep you aware
and inspired yeah
um I would say
is probably the most important factor
always ask the why behind things because
then that's going to fuel the what if we
can do so
um I have a habit of asking seven
questions whenever I'm speaking to
someone just to get to the heart of what
we really need to know what really is
going on and I think what's key for us
to keep moving us forward is not
accepting that it's just the way we've
always done it so that's what we're
going to do so we definitely push more
to see what if and what else and what's
next rather than just what is
I love that curious you know it's funny
curiosity is one of the main traits we
look for when we're hiring Talent at
Gallery Media Group we think it's what
allows you to not become obsolete in
whatever craft you have and when you're
curious and when I started in the media
and tech industry because I came from
the finance industry 12 years ago
the only thing I knew how to do was just
ask a million questions until someone
was like get out of the room of your
annoying me at this point because that's
the way you learn it's the way you stay
curious
I love that that's part of the answer
there and I know you know it's only been
a year for you so far at Samsung in this
role what do you think the best lesson
you've learned in that last 12 months
has been
well I'd have to say it's just making
sure you have all the right people at
the table to start because if on the
ground floor you're bringing in all the
different groups like for me I'm over
home entertainment so that's TV's audio
and memory but then we want to bring in
our counterparts on home appliances and
in display and in Mobile and make sure
we're connecting with our corporate
marketing team so that you have all the
right people sitting at the table from
the onset you're going to ensure that
you're thinking of every touch point
that a consumer is going to have in
their whole journey and after purchase
like we want to have relationships with
our consumers we don't want it to be a
once and done type of deal so I think
starting at the beginning with that
we're all in this together mindset
really helps with driving the thought
process that we're thinking about every
single component that could possibly
come into play
and there's a lot of aspiring
um marketers on here folks that are in
marketing that are looking for for jobs
and obviously with someone like your
infectious energy or someone they might
be drawn towards and want to work for so
I'm curious when you do see resumes come
across your desk or you interview folks
what are certain qualities you look for
when when you're hiring people or they
want to get into marketing that you look
for yeah I would definitely say
um an EQ is as as important as an IQ I
want someone that has those soft skills
that human side that also is a go-getter
you know they're very proactive I'm much
more impressed with someone who's come
in and did their homework and they're
resourceful and they're going to be able
to creatively problem solve than someone
that is just a rule follower and only
doing it by the book and not thinking
outside of the box so I think that
Curiosity like you said that comes into
play but definitely proactiveness and a
resourcefulness is what I really look
for when I'm talking to people and we
are always hiring so hit me up on
LinkedIn if you are looking because I'd
love to talk you heard her hit her up in
the DMS and Linkedin get in there
um awesome speed round questions we're
going to get to know Sarah here a little
bit better
um Ireland or Italy you knew that this
would be an easy one for me so my
husband's from Ireland of course I have
to say Ireland okay Billy Joel or Elton
John well ironically I'm gonna say both
because one of my first concerts was the
two of them in concert together no way
where was that it was at Penn State
where I went to college however I am
from Allentown Pennsylvania so I got to
give props to the Allentown song even
though it is not really about Allentown
it's actually about Bethlehem just more
words rhyme with Allentown okay I like
it are you a beach person or Mountains
for vacation
I guess Beach where my voracious reading
comes into play but if I really had my
choice I'd pick anything historical
because I like learning the backstory oh
interesting and last one you got to give
me the product you never leave home
without
well this is too much of a softball of
course it's my Samsung Galaxy old phone
I use it because it opens up so I can
read big documents on it and I also can
stay in touch with my teenagers since
they do not respond to anything but
snaps
I know the feeling my niece is the same
thing they all communicate via quick
Snapchat text it's wild we'll be in the
same house and I can only communicate
with them that way so I could not live
without my phone
I love it well Sarah thank you so much
for joining us today we really
appreciate it and we will see you soon
thank you Sarah we'll see you soon and
thank you Ryan love those speed rounds
all right we'll talk to you I want to do
one with you one time we're going to do
one we're gonna do them together but not
today let's do it for the company
internally okay that sounds good all
right we'll see you soon all right next
we're gonna welcome up Chris Anthony who
is the chief Revenue officer of gallery
Media Group hey Chris how's it going I'm
good Andre how are you I'm good I'm
really excited about this chat with
Jamie Jamie leads the global ax
marketing team at Unilever
and he's he's a firecracker for a bunch
of reasons he is constantly looking for
new ideas for the company and how to
build communities whether it's in social
media or the metaverse but also fun fact
I don't know if you know this Chris
about Jamie but he can catch any food
item in his mouth when it's thrown at
him I feel like that's kind of how he
how he moves through his life so I'll
leave it up to you guys
I love it Jamie good to see you hi Chris
how are you good good hopefully you're
gonna catch some dinner in your mouth
soon as I know it's your time a little
bit later over your way but yeah that's
the only way I was fed as a child so you
know it's a conversational survival
skill the hungry last one
um so great to have you on market for
the now today so we'll Jump Right In you
know the the theme of today cracking the
code on Speed and Agility so excited to
kind of talk about acts the work you've
done and sort of personally how you've
navigated that theme to kick things off
talk about just why do you think Speed
and Agility is so important to cpg
Industry overall even specifically a
personal care thematically
yeah sure I think that you know for a
brand like ax but any fmcg brand yeah
and you know the best way for us to
connect with with consumers is by moving
at the speed of culture and
um you know we have a goal as a brand uh
where we want to be the most talked
about brand in the world with Gen Z and
the only way for us to do that is to
move quickly
um you know we looked at you know tons
of data around gen Z and one of the
things that we found was most striking
was that 91 of gen Z believed that
mainstream pop culture is dead and that
means that in the past where Brands were
able to just kind of put themselves into
football or basketball or whatever it
was that isn't enough anymore and so you
need to go into those subcultures that
exist within the kind of mainstream
cultures and so you know an example of
that and how we've done that has been
um through cryptocurrency so we knew
that that was a kind of a really big
trend for our audience as a brand and we
were sort of struggling with a way into
that
um but on uh 420 actually in 2021
um we were working on a brief on the day
which was more of a traditional 420 uh
brief and actually on the day we started
seeing a kind of conversation bubbling
up we talk about velocity of a
conversation and all around the Doge
Army trying to get the price of Dogecoin
to a dollar and so we decided to Pivot
the creative away from 420 to sort of
say that we created a post we mocked up
a can with ax and Dogecoin together and
we said that if the price hits a dollar
we'll make it happen and this post's
been absolutely viral it was electric
and we got two billion impressions in
less than 24 hours which is more than
any Super Bowl ad has got with all of
the money that they spend on those and
and we ended up making it selling it for
Dogecoin and selling out in in point one
of a second so it really kind of shows
the value when a brand can move at the
pace of culture so wild so amazing and
redefine what 420 means for a million
different reasons
um pretty awesome you talked a little
bit about culture and just sort of
relevance which is something we talk a
lot about here
um talk about how Talent how does Talent
sort of inform when you talk about
culture and reality events and talk
about some of the work of leveraging
talent overall for Acts yeah sure so you
know this year we've signed little baby
in the US and obviously a huge artist
and and you know for us it's been a real
game changer in the way that we've
started working with Talent so in the
past where we might have thought about
social activation using talent and kind
of left it there we've really integrated
little baby into the full campaign so
you see him in the TVC he's he's
recorded the soundtrack but we've kind
of used every touch Point all the way
through to in-store and so a full
integration and what we're seeing is
that that is really kind of paying
dividends with regards to our social
currency you know we measure you know
what's the perception of the brand in
terms of talkability as well as kind of
coolness and cool perceptions and the
little baby stuff has been a real step
change for us in the way that you know
that kind of delivers uh you know kind
of brand credibility and you know what's
been very important for us as well has
been to tap into his audience rather
than just kind of slapping acts onto you
know a little baby ad or vice versa
we've really kind of spent time
understanding his audience and what
important to them so we created you know
a couple of tick tock uh collab ads with
him and actually last week we put a post
out with him and it's his most viewed
Tick Tock of all time and I think for a
brand to do that is quite rare and so it
really kind of shows the the value in
getting to know that audience and then
using talent but integrating them in a
way that feels native to Their audience
rather than just a brand really clumsily
coming into that space
such a great partnership congrats on
that so amazing you you touched on Tick
Tock a couple times
um go a little deeper there you know how
how much is Tick Tock sort of the future
of Acts and are there other sort of
Innovations you know in kind of keeping
up with this trend of sort of always
being ahead of like what is next
um talk a little bit more about that
sure so we spend a lot of time and we've
invested a lot of energy into
understanding what are the up and coming
platforms and obviously Tick Tock at the
moment is the real kind of buzzword and
you know it's where we need to be I
think it's changed a lot for us and you
know if you think about Tick Tock
compared to some of the other social
platforms where you know Instagram for
example where everything's really uh you
know kind of beautified and curated Tick
Tock you need to be a little bit more
kind of rough and ready and that's been
a big shift for us to make both as a
sort of an internal brand Team but also
with our agencies and we've kind of
taken you know I think three things on
board with Tick Tock one is test and
learn in everything and it's quite
empowering to have you know leaders who
allow us to fail you know three out of
ten of the posts that we kind of do on
Tick Tock might work and that's okay
um as long as we take those learnings
done is better than perfect and you know
obviously we want to get as close to
perfect as possible but again with Tick
Tock you kind of want it to feel more
real and so done is better than perfect
is great for us and then finally and I
think probably most importantly
um it's fragrance at the heart of
everything that we do it you know I
think it's it's so easy for Brands to
just go viral on a social platform and
deliver no long-term brand value and you
know we might have been guilty of that
in the past but we've now boiled down
that every single post that we put out
there goes through a checklist of is you
know does this land fragrance in some
way and you know that has been a real
step change for us and making sure that
we are building a long-term brand
proposition rather than just putting
stuff out there for the sake of it to
get clicks and likes yes so smart it's
interesting I feel like the the
perfectionist is dead it seems in a lot
of the training the conversation to your
point Tech talk has sort of allowed us
all to kind of lean in and and not be
scared to kind of make those failures
and learn so such a great point
pivoting a little bit to shopping
knowing that the consumer Behavior has
just changed so much in the last two
years and you're obviously gen Z
consumer just will probably forever shop
differently than past consumers has that
changed sort of your marketing and sort
of how you think about reaching them
just massage perspective
uh I think there are certain trends that
we're looking at
um you know Tick Tock live as a shopping
um program is one that we're now looking
into and live Commerce uh we're also
really diving into what would the impact
of social commerce look like for us and
how could that look so that we're not
only a brand that you find at Walmart
but also a brand that you can find you
know online and again actually the
Dogecoin example and a couple of others
that we've we've launched have been
really
inspirational for us where we've
actually seen consumers who've got their
hands on some of those limited editions
that we've dropped and sold or given
away for free reselling for thousands of
dollars online whether that's on eBay or
someone turn the Dogecoin pack into an
nft and sold it for tons uh you know on
openc and and we sort of tap we're
starting to work on tapping into how
could that
um become a new Commerce platform for us
moving forwards
right so smart
Switching gears a little bit talk about
culture so you guys are obviously
Unilever is a very large organization
and sometimes you know to move quickly
um can take a lot of people to make that
happen how have you how how have you
used that sort of agility and speed
within the organization to get things
done that the audience can learn I can
learn
um what give us some talk about that a
little bit
sure so you know large organizations so
we have large Frameworks
um I think the biggest set change for us
has been the fact that we've worked
really hard at bringing some of those
parties that may have been blockers in
the past into the briefing process so uh
legal for example where if we were
trying to push the boat out and do
something new and something different
may have been challenges but they've
been in the room from day one so rather
than coming to them with what we think
is a solution and seeing problems
they're working on Solutions with us and
I think that's that single kind of
action has been the biggest game changer
for us and something that will continue
to take forward
I love that legal is our friend early on
um
and kind of in that same point you have
a lot of agencies how do you sort of
balance you know giving them the keys to
the kingdom you sort of having that
ownership being able to move quickly and
sort of balancing outside the walls of
Unilever how does that work
yeah absolutely we've we've got amazing
agencies um which helps
um but I think working on you know we
work incredibly closely with them uh so
we're on WhatsApp we're on iMessage
we're on teams constantly bouncing ideas
off of each other so that builds up a
real degree of trust
but also we try and keep the filters
really simple so that we're not a brand
team that is constantly looking for
approvals or multiple rounds of
approvals we keep it really simple and
we say to you know they have the same
framework as us does it smell good in
terms of what we're putting out there
has it got a sort of cheeky confidence
that ax is famous for and does it have
some sort of Fantastical element to it
and the the freedom that that has given
them has been massive so quite often now
actually you know our agencies are based
in the states and we'll wake up to posts
that we never saw that have gone live
and I think that's probably the thing
that we're proud of and that I'm proud
of is that the agency have the room and
the freedom to be actually putting
incredible work out there that doesn't
need to go all of those multiple rounds
and I like to think that we're really
not a blocker we're more of an enabler
of that way of working within our
Network
mm-hmm love that last question what's
sort of like your personal hack
um to kind of be quicker sort of be more
agile from a personal standpoint when it
comes to all these things
I mean I'm obsessed with data
um we use loads of real-time analytics
tools and so we look at velocity uh of
Trends and and that's been a real game
changer I guess for me but also the
teams that we work with are really
immersed in this culture and I think you
know I use anime as an example I'm not
personally into anime but we're seeing
it really growing as a trend and having
people in our teams and agencies who are
able to identify that and listening to
them and giving them a voice has been
the enabler in allowing us to kind of
jump on those uh on those Trends and so
I think it's a mix of data Obsession and
then really immersing yourself into
those worlds and having a bit of faith
in the people who really know them
awesome so great I've learned so much
about this and it sounds like you guys
are doing some incredible work at rapid
fire speed which is really awesome uh
thank you Jamie so much
thanks Chris
thanks Jamie time for dinner
all right Chris
I'm excited about this next conversation
as well we've got Samir Agarwal who's
from Clinique North America
and Samir oh I oh love that background
Samir amazing thank you Samir you have
quite the statistics here you lead a 45
person team with 150 million dollar
budget and it sounds like you've had a
real turnaround in terms of both sales
and uh share growth uh which has led to
revenue of over 1.2 billion dollars for
the Clinique brand can't wait to hear
this story
thank you so sad to be here
yes we are too Samira so great to see
you
yeah good to see you too first
awesome
um kicking things off excited about this
excited to hear what's happening in the
world of Clinique a little deeper uh
talk a little bit about you know
Clinique is a Heritage brand you guys
have been around for a long time and
really are Cornerstone in the beauty
industry why is this so incredibly
important to you being able to be agile
in the beauty space especially at a
Heritage brand
yeah I mean it's incredibly vital Chris
I mean if you think about it right we
and a lot of your speakers this morning
have already spoken about this right
we've got speed of Trends right which
can pop up in two to six weeks we've got
speed of competition every day
somebody's coming to me be like hey have
you heard of this beauty brand have you
seen this beauty product and I'm like
honestly no because there's so much
changing so quickly and then as you guys
know the speed of consumers and their
attention is getting smaller and smaller
and so when you think about being a 55
year old brand in category that is
driven by newness and the new hot thing
um our challenge for Clinique is like
how do we make it a brand of today right
and so when you compete in a category
like that and you have a history and
Heritage like we have every time you're
not of the moment you're only
reinforcing that you're 55 years old and
so the real challenge for us is like how
do we take a brand that has so much
history so much trust but have it feel
like a brand that modern consumers want
to use today
um is really important Speed and Agility
are just like vital parts of that right
totally and and the opposite of the 55
year old from a consumer standpoint is
obviously gen Z who you guys are doing a
really great job
um at reaching talk about how the brand
is really responding to gen Z as a
consumer things that you guys are kind
of doing to make sure you're getting in
front of that consumer you know faster
more relevant in that way right
so I think that there's a few things
that I'd like to highlight here because
they've been a big part of our success
in our turnaround is first is and you'll
hear me talk about this a lot throughout
our conversation is humility like I
think the first thing we need to
acknowledge was like we are not gen z
um I am not gen Z and I don't think that
I can speak to gen Z in a way that's
authentic and real so one of the things
that we did is that we just relaunched
our College ambassador program so now
we've got 50 college students across the
country at like high population
universities actually embracing Clinique
as their own brand posting on their
social handles and their natural
language
um and talking about Clinique is if it's
their own brand and so that's a really
great way for us to actually be of the
moment because we've got to acknowledge
like I don't know what a college student
in at Penn State or a Tufts University
or wherever it might be how they want to
hear about my brand
um and so empowering those students to
do their postings to do their Eventing
and their sampling opportunities really
gets us to be in the moment the second
thing is
um we do believe that Tick Tock right
now and Snapchat as well are two of the
most important channels to be on for
this consumer and so we've been doing a
ton of experimentation on Tick Tock um
both in terms of how we react to trends
that we're seeing how do we see Trends
and then how do we come up with a
consistent presence that allows people
to realize that we're here and that
we're we can be when we're a part of
their lives
um and then the last thing is Snapchat
which um I continue to believe that like
AR will continue to be a massive trend
for Genesee consumers because they just
want greater levels of interactivity
with Brands and not just messages even
from influencers that are credible
um that they just watch and view they
want greater activity interactivity so
that's a big trend for us as well love
that I love the idea of you guys using
consumers as sort of influencers in the
college program so incredibly smart and
just you know creates a bigger sort of
culture of
amplification I think that's so great
that sort of same vein of you know in
real life and things that people are
craving more than ever now how are you
guys approaching you know not outside of
tick tock and outside of the platform
through experiential I think you guys
have done some interesting things talk a
little bit about that I think that's
such a big part of consumers want now
and especially you know the Gen Z
consumer
yeah so I think one of the things that
we're seeing post coven well there's two
things I'd say I think the macro Trend
that I'm feeling a lot is and you guys
have are touching on a lot is culture
today is more personal and more fluid
than ever before right so people are
moving from one aspect of a subculture
to the next throughout the day and the
week right whether it's I have a passion
for tennis I can spend hours just on
Tick Tock tennis content right
um but then the next minute I might be
thinking about like oh I love cars and
so then I have like an hour of this and
there's subcultures around all of these
things and all of our passion points and
so one of the things that I think we've
been trying to figure out is when as
people are doing that what are the true
moments of influence within those
subcultures and finding those places of
authentic connection between our brand
point of view consumers passions and
interests and key moments is really
important for us and so what we've tried
to do is particularly post covet is
balance this digital presence in those
moments of influence but also in real
life moments I think that you know
whether it's we're we're going to be one
of the exclusive Beauty sponsors of
culturecon this coming Saturday
um an incredibly important venue for
um people who are incredibly influential
within the African-American Community
um and it's a place that we want to make
sure that we're showing up and showing
up is the best of Clinique so that those
cultural influencers can then bring
Clinic back to their moments of
subcategory or cultural influence that
they have so things like that are really
important and then obviously there's
incredible ability to create content in
those moments that showcase the
commitment we have to these communities
um through programs like that so that's
a big one the other thing that another
good example would be
um you know we have a member of my team
that actually is of Mexican descent and
she said Samir you know we're not doing
nearly enough against Hispanic consumers
around authentic moments of culture and
she's like take the Day of the Dead is a
major event in Mexican culture we could
be doing so much more and so we went
from we did like a four-month program of
her mentioning that in a meeting to
designing a custom package to launching
it in Market this October
um with a really amazing like Mexican
artist and so it's I think finding those
moments of where great ideas Bubble Up
on your team and getting out of the way
and empowering them to go get great work
done is another big part of this too
love that and it's definitely from a
multicultural marketing perspective that
came up obviously with Carlos Malta
Beauty and it sounds like you guys are
really you know being really thoughtful
but getting out things really quickly
which is such great kudos to you guys on
that front
Switching gears a little bit um there's
always been the old adage that the
beauty industry is Recession Proof
um and it is definitely probably true to
a degree obviously there's a lot of you
know challenges
um for the future or we're in them now
from an economic standpoint how has that
forced you to sort of think differently
from a marketing perspective obviously
the last two years have changed so much
but talk a little bit about that about
force you to change a bit with the times
right now
yeah so it's interesting Clinique plays
a really unique role within the beauty
industry if you think about it Chris
because there's obviously a lot of mass
players right that are in traditional
you know drug and food and and um super
center channels and then there's like
true luxury Prestige right like whether
that be like our sister Brands like
Lemaire for example right and Clinique
actually sits right in the middle of
that equation because we are very very
um cost effective relative to prestige
players
um but we're more expensive obviously
than the traditional channels that you
traditional Brands you see in mass and
so as we think about the environment
that we're in both from a culture
standpoint and like a recession
standpoint economic standpoint the
biggest thing for us is continue to
emphasize why we're worth it right like
why are we worth trading up for mass and
how are we more effective than some of
the luxury players that we compete with
and so that's been a really big Central
Anchor Point for us over the last three
years that I don't think is going to
change as we go into this coming moment
of economic uncertainty for people is
continuing to reinforce what are our
products deliver why are they different
and what do they actually do in terms of
driving great skin or makeup outcomes
that people want
um how we deliver that message right
could be very different right in terms
of how we have that show up on Tick Tock
versus how we do it in in paid social
but that I think that core tenet of we
are worth the money I think has got to
be something we got to continue to
emphasize because I do think we're
seeing particularly post covet a real
Resurgence and interest in Beauty right
um because people are socializing more
they're engaging more and I think it's a
little bit of normalcy that people are
still craving to get back to right I
think we're still feeling a bit of covet
hangover so that's part of me yeah yeah
and to your point you guys have an
amazing product so the times like this
you know it's it's probably makes it
easier for the consumer to choose that
from a product users which is great last
question you touched about this a little
bit but just from a personal standpoint
what's good advice to kind of how you
inject sort of Speed and Agility into
whether that be your personal Samira
um or your team overall talk a little
bit about that yeah so I think one of
the things that I always believed is a
big part of my job is getting out of the
way and creating space for people to do
good work so one of the things that I
always try to emphasize for my team is
that like one of our big values that
we've tried to emphasize is bolder
bigger marketing ideas have to come from
our team and so I think creating an
environment where people feel confident
they can bring those ideas forward is a
big one I think number two is
um I'm surrounded by an incredibly
diverse group of people on my team right
even just my My Consumer engagement team
you know we've got great multi-ethnic
representation
um great diversity representation and
those guys are constantly telling me
about what's going on out there and they
know that I want to hear that I'm hungry
for it
um and we even have bi-weekly team
meetings where we have people bring in
their favorite competitive products
because we want people to be Beauty
junkies we want them to like thrive in
this industry and search out what the
latest and greatest thing is so we all
know about it
um and so that's a big part of what we
do to try and make sure that we're
staying ahead of what's going on in
terms of Trends and then the last piece
is just a lot of personal curiosity you
know I'm not a big native Tick-Tock user
I'm not a big native Snapchat user but I
spend a lot of time on those platforms
because and I encourage my team to spend
a lot of time on those platforms because
if you're not in it if you're not living
it as close to it as you can and then
also bringing that sense of humility
that you won't always get all of it it's
hard to appreciate the impact these
platforms can have so yeah it sounds
like you have an incredible team and now
you're talking about a tennis on Tick
Tock Clinique collaboration because it
sounds like that's where you spend most
of your time which sounds exciting also
a lot of blackhead popping videos but
yes I agree yeah so right right
awesome well Samir this was so great
thank you so much learned a ton
um thanks again for joining us all right
thank you thank you
and and thank you Chris for joining us I
always love your conversations yes thank
you so much for having me we will see
you soon
all right last and but not least we have
Nick miritas EVP and so much more of
vaynermedia what's up Nick hello hello
hello
how are you doing I haven't seen you in
a minute oh my gosh I need a beauty
makeover after that conversation that's
what I'm realizing but you know what
good news what do you got there okay
someone left this in my office about 20
minutes ago I just wanted to let
everybody know I'm very excited about
this
all right put that away because we are
going to talk some serious mattresses
right here right now we've got the chief
marketing officer of Casper we love her
dearlytham you got it she oversees all
things marketing and it's a very long
list by the way brand Creative Media CRM
e-commerce and data we are so excited to
have you here
beautiful can we do this next time in
Brooklyn like we were yesterday
absolutely absolutely
thank you so much for joining
um why don't we start with and we only
have 10 minutes we gotta go a little
quick quick is a little bit about you
your role kind of new at Casper what's
going on at Casper I am very new to
Casper I think I'm uh officially three
months in but um let me tell you let me
start a little bit about me I am a
consumer-centric marketer and it's funny
as Samir was finishing up there um
because my most recent stop before
Casper was L'Oreal so very familiar with
that Prestige Beauty World but I was
thinking through it and thinking through
even my time at L'Oreal
um I started my career a very long time
ago in the retail space but I've always
thought about the world and I go through
the world and Nick you've seen this with
working with me thinking through the
eyes of the consumer so um a Casper I'm
very much doing that right so it's a DSC
darling only an eight-year-old company
and thinking through the consumers that
we started with eight years ago and the
consumers we want to reach now are a
little bit different so what does that
mean about what we need to do and how we
need to operate and how we need to
activate those consumers
all right cool so consumer centricity
Speed and Agility the theme why is that
important how do you think about Speed
and Agility as a marketer
um I well look I actually think it's
funny and almost tried the last three
years like
marketers and meet consumers where they
are right that's what I've always
believed and what has happened to the
world in the last couple of years like
nobody expected it so if you didn't have
the ability to move quickly and Agility
you lost and there were a lot of losers
throughout the coveted period
um and that was just one example right I
think the new proliferation of platforms
and how consumer behavior is
dramatically changing marketers and
organizations have to be there to to
follow that consumer and be agile and
quick to meet where they are because
that's that's how the winners are
defined
yeah it seems like there's you know I
was just coming off a phone call here
where we're pitching ideas through text
message oftentimes I know you and your
team like I have not seen many
PowerPoint decks since we've been
working together
okay we're doing this I guess like
that's how it's done now but I think um
had some real fun in the past few months
building some really
speedy and agile stuff together
um what's going on in the world of Speed
and Agility with you know uh Casper
right now so I think um again you talk
about quick I've been here three months
and
um right uh their opportunity was ripe
right when I started um that we we've
launched and hopefully many of you out
there have seen it a the our newest
Campaign which is called sleepers which
is in the market
um but it came extremely organically
from the consumer so we had posted a
tick tock of a of a guy sleeping in one
of our Stores
um in which there was immediate organic
reaction
um millions of views 24 hours and the
comments were actually what were the
most rich consumers really wanted to be
a part of and they connected like they
love sleep they wanted to sleep they
were like is this a job they were like
can can I get is he is he sleeping is he
getting paid to sleep and so what we did
is we immediately reacted we brought
that back to the team and we thought
very quickly and said okay what if we
make it a job
um and we came out and we respond funded
and we hit the market with a actual true
job and and look we we say this Speed
and Agility what actually went on behind
the scenes at Casper was fascinating
because it's we're not just telling the
marketplace we create a job we worked
with our HR team we worked with Google
we got everything together we're like
what does we need to pay these people we
thought about how how does this
internally will this be accepted so you
know we went through that and we created
um we created a job and over 3000 people
applied for three spots
um but we hired three three sleepers we
actually our two sleepers one of them is
a job
um happy who's wonderful
um but the the community responded
resoundingly and um tons of press and
attention around it but to me that's
just one example of how we are we are
thinking very very quickly and moving
quickly
um to meet the consumers and meet our
community based on what they want yeah
definitely I've seen it for sure on the
com side we're all kind of getting there
you can make that machine go faster one
thing I've been Amazed by and just shout
out to you and the team is on the
product side you know adapting in the
context of the moment whether it just be
what's going on in the world the economy
this or that I think the story of what
you're doing there might be really cool
for the audience yeah listen I actually
think it is much harder
um but it also goes to a to a team right
at the organization Casper is much
smaller than some of my past experiences
which makes it easier
um so uh the story there that I think is
insightful and interesting and
um one that again I I walked into a
little bit of the seeds had been set and
it started but many people may know this
many people may not but the mattress
industry and mattress sales are a
leading indicator of a recession so we
saw this at Casper beginning in December
of last year sales really started
slowing and then January hit and it it
got worse so our team looked at that and
said okay well what do we need to do and
the challenge was we need to come to
Market with a lower price and and we've
actually done some testing interesting
enough on our website of well what if we
go and mark down and sensitivity around
price and so the objective was we need a
market that's under a thousand dollars
um so we challenged all of our teams um
to go and do that and we were able to
launch our new element Pro which came
out last month very quickly record time
um but we did it by you know working as
a team and and leaning on each other and
trusting each other
um which to me actually is one of the
really key things behind Speed and
Agility right is the trust oh yeah if
you don't have that like it falls apart
quickly exactly because that's how
you're able to move so fast I think like
maybe cool for our audience it's just a
question on my mind is you know you've
lived in a L'Oreal type Big World you've
lived now in the d2c world and I think
there's some like you know bias and well
indeed to see they can move fast right
like what are some insights on because
you've probably seen different levels of
Speed and Agility based on the type of
company the culture the size yeah
personal insights or unlocks that if
somebody's watching right now is just
like oh wow like I can go kind of think
about that in my business today or with
my brand or my team
um what comes down I mean interestingly
Nick it's kind of what I just said to me
the biggest is trust right so I think
um yeah with DLC you have less people
it's easier to move quicker I think
sometimes in larger organization it is
there's bureaucracy or red tape people
call it or there's processes or you need
this more sign-offs but a lot of times
the reason you know if you look back on
why does this process exist why does a
sign off exist it's a lack of trust or a
lack of judgment so my my guidance and
reflection is if you find your yourself
in a situation in which I'm not moving
as fast it's like how do you look Inward
and say okay how do we establish your
credibility with the Partnerships
because
a lot of times it's cross-functional
Partnerships how do we move fast checks
and balances
um and so and again in these couple of
stores at Casper that's what we did
right and a lot of it is leaning on the
relationships the trust that you have in
each other
um I saw it a lot with sleepers honestly
um with even like HR right HR is
honestly involved for Speed yeah we kind
of builds a not for Speed absolutely and
I love and I even remember the very
beginning when those Partners came out
they were like wait why why does the
marketing team want HR involved in the
marketing campaign but it was like
because you're you're the experts and
this is what we're going to do and we
trust you and and so it that I really
think it comes down to that
speed permeating through every
discipline it's a cool thing absolutely
I think we've probably got time for like
30 seconds before we uh before we move
on but um you know
um any word final thoughts words of
wisdom things that are you're looking
forward to and technology or things that
are enabling greater speed anything
interesting obviously for me I think the
big one is text and I think my teams are
kind of like sick of me and some teams
and others are really excited by it
because it's a lot but I feel like
creativity over text is something that's
going to get very interesting I I think
we've done enough decks as an industry
and like the best thing is happen
through text like someone in the store
I'm gonna go to sleep I completely agree
with you and I think um look I I think
when you look at Asia you see a lot of
this as like the the company the brand
consumer engagement with text and I
think
in in our Market we were walking a fine
line because look everyone is in a date
of the email right and I think that yes
that's kind of been done but how do you
use that as an engagement because yeah I
think the average consumer like you're
talking we're talking about how we are
doing business on it but then it's like
there's an expectation of consumers of
getting stuff done or talking to each
other it's it's really interesting I
think it's a great space that we're all
gonna have fun with
um in the future I'm ready to shop for a
mattress we text
they're probably going to be trying it
very cool well I can't thank you enough
I can't wait for what's next and thank
you for joining us and we'll uh hand it
back to Andrew
okay thanks to you both thank you love
love that was really great all right
ciao
well thanks everybody for staying on we
know this was a special episode and we
had lots of voices to share with you an
extra
um extra long show so shout out to all
of you for staying on we've got another
episode of marketing for the now on
October 25th from noon until 1pm eastern
time where we're going to talk about TV
3.0 so please join us for that special
episode we'll see you very soon